I can't really think because every time
I say anything all I can hear is myself
it's like that thing in it the thing
where you her you're talking you can't
hear yourself what is it data ramming
ear cuff uh Flynn can't remember put up
on the screen so where have you been
charlie
well I've been working on a top-secret
project so that's gonna be fun to tell
you about cuz I can't actually tell you
anything can I what can I tell you we
have an office I'm doing the project
with my friend Jimmy I'll show you
around or how about I show you around on
this little thing I'll point out many
features number one wallpaper it's got
diamonds on it so modern table super
desk as we call it got a plant as well
haven't watered it in a long time still
seems to be doing fine we have a
traditional pile of rubbish in the
corner because we we got desks didn't
buy ourselves a bit let's see if I can
give you some kind of subtle hint about
what's coming it will be the most
important meal of your day what else
have I been up to I have been very busy
but I also have a terrible memory I was
in Canada my lovely girlfriend Emily
went over there to shoot a short film in
her hometown and I came along
mostly for moral support but I did do
some work on the movie as well I was the
editor it will be coming up very soon I
have no idea when it's pretty much done
but I don't know when it's coming out
it's called cold Emily has actually
given me special permission to show you
the first frame of the movie so nobody's
seen any of this film yet apart from now
that is actually the first frame of the
movie it's the best I could do sorry how
about the 48th frame of the movie boom
oh that actually looks like something
doesn't it it was bloody coat as well
when we were there like I remember going
to that beach to do a location recce
and it was like visiting the Arctic it
was kind of insane
speaking of short films actually while
I've been away
I have also encouraged my friend Johnny
Johnny even to design some posters for
all of my short films they're not
completely finished and they're not for
sale yet so guess this is a teaser well
do as I'll show you the two that are
finished don't they look pretty cool
actually
speaking of flogging things do I have
something for sale or dftba I have not
told you about yet do you remember when
I went to go and make my own special
blend of quality tea
well that tea is now for sale in little
pouches and now that I've told you about
that I can finally open this packet and
start drinking it myself it is genuinely
my favorite tea in the whole world
and because we did initially make it for
charity as well I am going to donate
five dollars American dollars from every
pouch that we make to comic relief so if
you would like some of that that's on
sale you can find a link somewhere I've
put it nearby a promise and to balance
out that's horrendous commercialism when
I tell you about the good thing I did
recently you might recall in the last
video I was encouraging people to come
to a blood drive well that has now
happened and I think it went really well
it was pretty sure notice inviting
people to come along so I was pretty
worried that nobody would show up at all
but in the end I think we had like 40
people I'm gonna say conservatively it
was 40 people came along and that is
what that's 40 pints of blood which is a
hundred and twenty potential lives saved
so pretty good way to spend an afternoon
you did a very good job do you know
everything probably not see you next
time you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
thank you everybody for watching if you
would like to see my previous video in
which I give blood over there if you
would like to watch a different video
because you have seen this one before or
you are not interested in watching a
video that contains blood and needles
which is fair enough
then why don't you watch this video
about production of aluminum cans cuz I
thought it was really interesting and
now every time I like drink from an
aluminium can
like oh that's all see you next time
goodbye